sally this is a sample room i'm going to
take you into now
for 10 days a room like this will be
home to red list arrivals
there's a microwave and fridge as well
so if they want their own drinks and
things
they can store that here covered
positive cases
are currently isolating in rooms here
they're a blueprint for how
quarantined hotels might work there's
about 2
000 people arriving per day at heathrow
gateway
and manchester um from the quarantine
countries
so for 10 days that's 20 000 rooms
so that's potentially 200 hotels with
100 rooms in each
we've been told enforced isolation is
coming
but the question they really want
answered here is when
we just desperately want to help and i
said i think that's the sense of
frustration is
we've sent all that information and just
not heard anything back
there are currently 33 countries on the
government's red list
including portugal south africa and
brazil currently
british and irish nationals and those
with residence rights who have traveled
to
or through those countries are able to
enter the uk
but must have a negative covered test
and self-isolate for 10 days
under the new proposals that would be in
government provided accommodation
anyone else attempting to enter the
country who's passed through the red
list
will be refused entry is this where
people come in
but as vaccine hope grows so too is
impatience
in the first wave 0.1 of cases came from
china
where we had restrictions 62 percent
came from france
and from spain where we didn't have
restrictions
and there's every reason to think that
the variant will behave in the same way
quarantining arrivals is an enormous
logistical challenge
hotels need to train staff make sure
passengers stay in their rooms
and they're asking who'll be responsible
for enforcing the rules
the governments say an announcement is
coming soon
there isn't a delay what there is is
work to make sure that the border
is always as secure as it needs to be
though the guests will be out of sight
soon this hotel may well be full for the
first time
in almost a year but for now they
continue
to wait ali fortescue sky news